and uh after move e6
then uh white has fianchettoed his light
squared bishop so now maybe we're gonna
see
white uh eventually might pick up the
queen's pawn and push it two squares
forward and nope black says absolutely
not and now the position becomes very
sharp yeah so the position could have
transposed into the catalan opening a
very famous opening a very trendy one as
well that levon has used with great
success in his career black duda here
has instead chosen a very ambitious
attempt and okay this bishop move uh at
least this type of idea was popularized
in the world championship match um when
magnus used it against janda pomnishi
eventually winning a very famous game
where there was a big blunder
so dude taking a leaf out of magnus's
book is this the same one though also
that we had wei yi versus aronian uh
where ye got a winning position at the
opening against ronin i am i'm trying to
work out from the last tour it's very
similar slightly different yeah slightly
different right okay yeah that one there
had already been a set of pawn exchanges
here there's been a set of minor piece
exchanges but all the pawns remain on
the board um there is a kind of semi
threat now of white's knight leaping
into the center hitting the black queen
will the black queen step back to
preempt that
yeah very ambitious by black i'm always
skeptical of black playing and getting
away with stuff like this just because
white's light squared bishop the bishop
in front of the white king is just so
potent on this diagonal
duda though isn't it i mean duder does
play very ambitious chess and he likes
keeping the pieces on the board he likes
space
and he wants to complicate
a typical maneuver here david and ivanka
the knight coming over yeah to to help
um push on the queen side et cetera yeah
it's going to move to c2 as as you see
there and then the big thing is going to
be white is desperately going to push
those pawns on the left and uh note the
way he does it because he pushes first
with the b3 pawn then it will be the a3
the a2 pawn annie
and uh then followed by the rook
yeah interesting it just looks a bit
slow for white i'm a bit skeptical of
this last pawn push i would have pushed
the other one
uh most likely but okay duder is to swap
a set of knights no no okay the knights
are dancing around black offers the
trade white says no we'll black retreat
now
so if if this is a draw which remind
everyone it goes to armageddon i love a
bit of armageddon you know
which is just one game that's it so
yeah and who will have the selection of
colors in the armageddon so apparently
judah had
the opportunity to choose in this one
and i'm actually not 100 sure why but he
is the highest rated player among these
two on the tour standing so i'm guessing
that is why yeah because i do think if
it goes to armageddon dude it's a
massive favorite ah he's just a bit
quicker on the mouse if he needs to be
i've played both of these two online at
blitz and i'm a bit
in terms of time in terms of clock usage
i'm a bit more uh confident in dude's
abilities there levon we've seen is
quick he's capable but if duda can
choose the white pieces have that one
extra minute um he very rarely draws
that many games anyway despite the
course of today's match uh so i think he
will choose white and he would love that
opportunity so a draw here for duda
would actually be a decent result would
anyone choose white now
do you think
i think both of these two players would
back themselves to choose white maybe
more solid players who are also
quick on the mouse they would choose
black
just to have that draw in hand in
armageddon but
i mean while a few changes white is
finally ready to start advancing pawns
on the left side on the flank on the
left flank but
black is looking pretty good in the
center maybe black moves bishop back now
try to stop those pawns from moving
it seems like black's making
okay progress to me um you know with
those pawns coming for us it could be a
little bit dangerous of white even yeah
i mean uh here comes another one but
isn't this a little bit too early after
all white is probably going to take that
born this is a very typical sacrifice in
it but this is a really brave move from
duda
and the point is that this is taken you
give up that pawn you have to give it up
and instead ronin counter attacks so
it's getting really wild now at the
moment yeah he kind of trusts uh duda a
little bit
i mean
hang on a second isn't this just maybe
quite nice for white
the acid test maybe would have been
capturing that black pawn in the center
but as you guys mentioned black would
get lots of activity there instead white
is just playing on the side where he's
stronger on this left flank uh you think
it's nice for white any specific reasons
i mean i i'm inclined to agree but i
can't really pinpoint the well essence
my my whole reasoning is because
whenever i've played this type of
position before whenever those pawns
have gotten motoring i find them very
very unpleasant to deal with
and uh yes you know what black's pawn
center looks very very impressive
but it's not actually doing anything you
look at black's bishop now it looks like
it's horrendous there is lots out of the
game
bishop yeah yeah can't do anything now i
mean it's totally on the wrong square
isn't it at the moment and uh
you know you're i think you're right
you've anchored those pawns in the
middle the black's got they may look
scary but without any backup of pieces
they're not doing anything you need a
knight on the other side of the board a
bishop on the other side of the board
you can't do anything just with one
queen behind them
so uh again like a battle you've sent
your foot soldiers forward but no kind
of cavalry infantry uh
to support them and look at the clock
times as well two minute advantage for
level ironing that's significant is it
i mean can levon get greedy and start uh
winning the pawns now the answer is yes
done
just in time anchor and
what is duda's plan oh just to capture
this port normally you would suggest
maybe advancing bypassing that pawn
locking in white's bishop behind its own
pawn but yeah now white's knight can
just drop into the center i mean i i was
going to say aronian won't get a better
chance than this he kind of had one in
the first game but he's getting another
chance here and you know he should be a
safe pawn up right with better pieces
after after this simple capture here
yeah i mean it's just that one piece
that's locked out of the game that black
a7 bishop yep
he's playing without a piece and no
attack will work if you're playing a
piece down and uh those light squares
around the black king i mean they're so
weak
i mean i i would be tempted to maneuver
a knight towards that direction and uh
you see levon do that i mean this is a
great move as well kind of night in
front of black's pawn and just
stabilizing the center of the board i
really like this idea
look at duda he knows he's in big
trouble already and he knows he's not in
the flow levon did make that switch from
rapid to blitz much better than him
look at the clock times yeah yeah
even if the position is hopeless you
can't be this far behind on the clock
yeah
well at least he's got rid of a white
light square bishop and that is the best
defender of white's king um so maybe
black can get something of the rook in
queens it's just i think it's just
coming back to black's bishop just look
at black's bishop it might as well be a
pawn you know there's no point having a
bishop there just swap it with a pawn
it's doing nothing
and that's the
the pro and you're pawn down as well so
it's not it's not just that piece yeah a
couple of issues to worry about here i
mean this last exchange you're swapping
off white's best piece but you're also
maybe getting rid of your own best piece
your own best minor piece so i'm
expecting maybe the white king to
capture this bishop and
just full control and the funny thing is
if you try to go b6 we can't probably
analyze it because the time but then you
can really lock that bishop in and
that's very amusing that you know i love
those kind of situations when you when
you see them you know so anyway the
game's developing quickly but yeah maybe
just while levon was thinking that just
to show because this is the key fact um
this this bishop is dead this bishop is
just staring at a white pawn and uh
white pawn chain and like you said simon
if you try and get it out now the knight
is kicked away and then now this bishop
is this
it's worse than a blackball at least the
black pawn could move this bishop
staring at its own pawn so dude is
playing a battle without
that piece and even if in a situation
like this even if black regains the pawn
and captures this guy
any end game is going to be winning for
white because this piece is so bad white
will simply eventually win it
so uh yeah he can bully him now aronian
with his clock advantage and with his
pawn advantage also with the advantage
of the better pieces this queen capture
is not good this bishop is oh i said
it's not good and he plays it let's play
commentator's curse but this bishop is
going to decide the game
maybe he had to grab it i mean what else
can you do you might as well grab a paw
and i suppose but i agree with you david
that
it's horrible you've actually totally
horrible and also there's a big threat
on the board you know white knight is
actually threatening to come to the f4
square attacking the rook and also
threatening to jump into g6
forking the king and rook
this is what we call positional
domination simply white's knights
especially the knight that's just moved
into the center in front of the black
pawn i mean they're just glorious
blockaders yeah the light squares and
dude is going down close to 30 seconds
not that much time difficult position
but great
[Laughter]
yep
fighting for his life here young
christopher duda but the bar is all the
way over to levon's side it's looking
good on the clock as well and uh
threats just keep on coming because now
levon is threatening to attack the
knight and destabilize the bishop this
is why duda moves it back to a
ridiculous looking square i mean i bet
you i bet you lev's probably enjoying
this now isn't he he must be enjoying
this position somewhat he's barely
paused for thought love on everyone i'm
so impressive yeah 13 seconds really
really really strong play by him yeah i
agree also to bounce back from the the
upset at the last game where he knows he
threw away the wing can you now play
this idea i i just want to play it but
then the rook gets a bit weirdly trapped
you know
we probably don't need to play here and
uh dude are trying to break out if you
can get his bishop out then he's in the
game
and levon going for the most direct
attempts he's threatening a bunch of
knight forks now black's knight had to
trade off now white's tonight wants to
jump forward with the check wants to
jump towards the black bishop it's going
to jump towards the the black bishop and
the knight oh sorry in the night the
rook yeah looks like it looks like a
killer
yeah it's just over here dude is about
to lose that terrible bishop to be
honest i don't even want to win it i
just want to yeah yeah just maybe push
your ball forward because you know what
it is david because you're one sadistic
player
you just love the torture
let's see if iranian is equally sadistic
is he going to go and try and win that
bishop immediately or is he just going
to say nope he's trapped anyway
push your pawn forward and lock it in
behind its own pawns i know what you
mean i i i would do the same
no
he goes
it's too tempting the lure of material
yeah i mean it is
it is a whole bishop i think safe bishop
yeah you can take that piece now it does
finally drop off the board that bishop
yeah i think it felt a relief without
being
still some work to be done because black
does have two very strong pawns and they
will connect and the night the night is
offside at the moment so you know if if
the pawns can go before the night gets
back um it's
some hope but
um not much
not much yeah white's knight rook and
king should connect uh they will combine
and coordinate in order to stop black's
pawns
ideally you want to stop i love this
move ideally you want to stop the black
king coming towards the center i was
going to say yeah
these pawns advancing alone shouldn't be
enough but now the king can kind of
approach
the pawn white king can come
and let's see lev on screen he's about
to play your move you've anchored the
white king centralizing yeah nice move
he's just playing by instinct levon but
he's also playing on general rules he
just saw his opponent had a locked out
piece he locked it in won it now he's
bringing his pieces together looks like
dude is out of
time on his clock keeps sticking down to
almost zero seconds
okay and again he's playing moves with
one two seconds on this clock dude
and last trick now but it's not gonna
work
his pawn can just be captured
and here
i mean there's not even a threat
really for black okay you can just go
and win this black pawn
and a whole night down
yeah it's hopeless
it's how you place yeah i mean
you might as well play on i guess
because uh you know um now slips power
outages
someone forgetting to plug in the laptop
there's uh
still some ways to save it
from his rook trade helps white
i mean black's remaining porn is going
to drop soon
beyond hopeless now
i think so yeah
yeah not much else to say unfortunately
for duda he's just going through the
motions levon still has two minutes
to spare two minutes in the bank i'm
impressed by the one in this game yeah
very impressive yeah the whole blitz
segment i mean i know he missed that win
or kind of let the win slip in the last
game but complete control both games
and duda i mean when he won the oslo
esports cup he was winning all the tie
breaks he played several tie breaks and
he won most of them aronians just
swatted him away in this one yeah
and i just like the way that he's using
all of his army here
you know the king the knight the work
all of them are working so well together
and uh now he just improves his work
getting ready for the king to step up
the board
and there's just nothing that dude can
do apart from weight
yeah
waiting when you're a knight and a pawn
down
it's not a fun task nope
but i think you just have to embrace it
and hope for the best because after all
the position is lost
reminds me another ending i think that
dude was involved i can't remember
against who where
where he where's the knight down as well
and he ended up losing in the end but
from another tour mm-hmm you saw one
comment
yeah but i like the fact that dude is
playing on yeah there are always a ton i
mean there's always half a percent
chance or one percent chance and you
know what i do here
[Laughter]
maybe there's some stalemate ideas as
long as black's king is on the edge of
the board there's always chances you
might accidentally trap it without
checking it yeah but uh yeah levon he's
found i think quite a nice way to
he's going to either trade rooks or he's
going to force the black king back
but i guess the ultimate idea for lebron
is to queen that form yes so he i have
to say that looks kind of hard because
there's a lot of uh stuff in front of
that pawn yeah not for long not for long
oh okay step by step so first he
protects his own pawn next he'll win the
black pawn and he'll get his own pieces
out the way and slowly start motoring
forward
so now he'll step is pawn forward he'll
win the black pawn guaranteed next move
and like slowly but surely baby steps
the pawn will step forward and
judo gives up hope he resigns it's over
another match win for levon aronian
today in tie breaks to gain 2